what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we're back with some new
shirts today
yeah doing it special for the bad batch
the biggest Star Wars show that's ever
existed and we're watching some episode
off of what doesn't matter it's the
title Michael how are you I'm so excited
yeah you guys have been following each
week I talk about where I'm at on season
three of the Clone Wars as I re-watch
yeah uh we just got past the Zillow
Beast I want to apologize because I feel
like sometimes I make fun of the early
seasons of Clone Wars and sure Zero The
Hut unnecessary but like it's really
great and I've loved re-watching it I'm
excited for for bad batch I just watched
uh the episode where you remember 99 yes
which of course is where we get clone
Force 99 there you know the bad batch is
named after him and so I'm especially
excited to just like I don't know going
back look into the future uh I feel like
I'm gonna have a lot of Easter eggs uh
so it's gonna be a fun time
there's a what a hell of an intro there
I've been I've had nothing to do this
week at The Logical of yours leave a
like for Michael like Mike like Mike and
uh of course pulling through action
watch alongs are on our patreon page
where you sync up with their own copy
let's get to it guys
[Music]
come on title What's it gonna be
the Clone conspiracy filler no no
such thing
ah chorus scant
[Music]
oh
gone it feels like a barn and or we were
following orders oh were we
then
and then why is grandpa covering it up
huh good question oh I can't stay silent
any longer no
what did you do
send a message to Rampart oh give him
the chance to tell the senate the truth
before I did it myself
ah crap that's bad news yep he's a goner
we're not bad men but what we did was
wrong please
I need your help
nope there it is like attack of the
Clones
I wonder who's on the other side of that
sniper Boba Fett
ah
[Music]
a
come on slip you got the beard man
go go go go go
all right that's cool that's pretty
awesome
[Music]
this really is a lot like attack of the
Clones yeah right
[Music]
I'll be good at dex's Diner soon oh
we got a clone conspiracy on our hands
without the production of new clone
troopers we are vulnerable Admiral
rampart's proposed defense recruitment
bill will keep us protected there's a
storm coming huh
then Chancellor Palpatine during the
separatist crisis shifting to a military
of citizens swearing loyalty
fundamentally goes against the
principles of this body and they might
not be good shots
the emperor trusts this delegation to
act in the best interest of all Galactic
citizens and what about the interests of
the clone troopers why are they not
included within this legislation she's
all grown up the Clone Army cannot
sustain given their accelerated aging
and should be slated for decommissioning
wow I thought you were a more
understanding
defended us defended our worlds is that
Omega in blueface if we don't who will
after all they have sacrificed you now
wish to discover them leave them with
nothing is that how we repay them for
their service her dad's George Lucas and
Revenge of the Sith
passioning a new Army without a plan in
place to care for our current one
got a ban bad feeling about this if we
work together we can adequately address
their concerns
until then I motion to table the vote on
the defense recruitment Bill
ramparts matter all his ethnic folks
once she's appeased the defense
recruitment bill will be approved long
before any of the provisions she's
seeking come to you for your sake
Admiral be certain there are no more
surprises
I love masameta so much
I'm glad we're getting some more screen
time with him I love Rampart I'm glad
we're getting more screen time Rampart
once a clone has completed the required
rotations yeah the Empire declares us
obsolete we know talking won't change
that I can craft a pension plan pension
plan I'd rather be out there fighting
those Insurgent groups that keep popping
up
okay and what happens when you're too
old to fight Oh Boy tell me how to help
and I will make sure Admiral rampart's
bill needs your needs
for now until she gets assassinated whoa
whoa
spoilers the only time to try to kill
Padme for trying to stop defensive
spoilers
[Laughter]
all right guys we're going to Pandora
do what I can
yeah
if they were true the Senate would know
someone would have come forward Rampart
made sure no one could cleanser tried to
speak up or either reside went missing
ended up dead
this is a great political episode so
good cto409
on senator be careful
slip away
it's great that we're getting this
transition and getting to see more of
the soul of the Clones yeah it's it's
just so nice to watch the rise of the
empire I mean devastating but nice
it's fun
[Music]
shot first they're so racist
there's a million of them in Star Wars
it's not Credo
heard you can help me get out but you
have to hurry I don't have much time
Rex
I'll help you right
you expect the Empire to fund a new
military and full pensions for millions
of Clone Troopers and 401ks
501st one case
nice thank you my priority is keeping
the Galaxy safe
but I do agree with you
no don't like this picture of the Clones
requires further discussion and planning
we owe them that for their service
clones know too much Rampart
the storm
that caused the cities don't say it how
is it that you survived
I'm a white man
the majority of the caminoan population
was lost at run
that is beyond tragic we must move
forward Perhaps it is easier for some
than others so it's not going to end
well
[Music]
you gotta kill a rampart send it
send it Crown crown
I think it's happening
[Music]
so an uprising begins yes yes indeed if
systems begin to revolt as they did with
the Republic that will threaten his new
Empire
damn right to polka City designed to be
submersible whether thousands of storms
over the years yet it suddenly wiped off
the map surprised more people aren't
suspicious
he said he was assigned to the ship that
opened fire we can convince him to
testify where is the Clone now in hiding
my guards are out searching be careful
you may not be the only one looking for
him I love Bale so much
I enjoy bail I love him he's so good
follow the senator if she finds him
handle it
Senator as well who is this guy that's a
great question
a new Assassin
character why would we introduce one of
those oh where's Luke
he's a touchy station to pick up some
power converters
you gotta give him slip
I'm at the rendezvous
where are you
okay that doesn't help us yeah whose
voice is that
easy Trooper
Senator you're a hard person to trick
down it is Omega blue face I'm leaving
once he gets here who someone who can
make me disappear where the Empire can't
find me how did you even find me were
you followed
can get to me
so can they give them this slip
those who perished including including
Lions who died trying to speak the truth
[Music]
must be held accountable
you don't need me the evidence you want
is a broad Rampart ship check the
Bridge's commandlock I'd be looking up
ahead thanks
well that's not the proof you need
let's go yes
yes I think he might be right
he's not gonna make it
nice shooting
oh my God bro ouchy
that's not cross here
once I got a new costume it's Kevin
two out of ten not enough hat I'll draw
them out one for the door get to the
speeder
I love the Ambiance of this episode
[Music]
all right if Rex is gonna show up now be
the time to do it
[Music]
so far the best episodes are the ones
that have the bad match agreed
[Applause]
[Music]
you're right it is my boy
slip told me about what truly happened
to Kamina
I wanted him to testify before the
Senate
someone was sent to make sure that would
never happen
no way
is not a trooper not sure what he is but
and I have just the place
ahsoka's house
not a gun Dylan chorus I go in deep deep
down 13-13 baby nah I think we're going
to ahsoka's house man
a couple of friends of mine on this
garage oh it could be Boba no he's not
oh the girls the women oh yeah oh yeah
you're fighting the wrong battle brother
you're limited
so what does that make you cool music
a Believer
oh come on
this is like attack of the Clones
interesting like hardcore
Imperial loyalist clones
Dave floaty
bad [__]
truth and consequences it's been good
titles I'm happy today you should have
read it before filming I want some Nerf
nuggets no
[Music]
back to the batch uh
hurry
padawan-like position there getting in
touch with the force I don't enjoy
solitude
I had enough of that on skako minor
if it weren't for this squad I'd still
be a prisoner there always talking about
your Chicago Miner
we have an incoming transmission
it's Rex
this episode's really connected what do
you need Rex oh
everything when you get to Corazon
yeah why what's on Corazon everything
the heart of the Empire but the Empire
thinks we're dead it's a covert Mission
a simple dated extraction
I'll send over a flight plan to bypass
Imperial Security and coordinates to a
safe landing rampart's Flagship for
evidence about Camino you guys should uh
invest in some makeup or uh facelifts
yeah maybe don't wear your clone armor
yeah
everyone
stay ready
[Music]
I just love course not so much I know
it's just like Scottsdale Arizona that's
exactly what it is yeah
it takes so much time for atmosphere and
it's so nice
this is Senator Rayo chuchi
these are the special clones I told you
about
hello
assassin
why would a clone be targeting another
clone
or a senator slit witnessed the truth
I wanted him to testify to rimpart's
crimes I can be your Witness
but there's another way to provide the
Senate with the evidence of the Empire's
crimes
the command log on rampart's venator ah
they that's what I said
where's the veteran now being
retrofitted at the Imperial Shipyard
right here on Coruscant but I know a way
in just stripping off the red paint
I'll return to the Senate and gonna
support where I can you could still be
in danger then I must be on the right
track that's true if you don't have
haters you're not doing something right
it really doesn't seem to do
same serve the Galaxy
voice of the
Peter price to see me Admiral I was just
making a few preparations for tomorrow's
vote I am looking forward to it
that Rampart ever meet
Omega
I don't think so
I've taken care of it
there's nothing else she can do
you had better hope so no more delays on
this vote Rampart such a [__] Rampart
this is where the Senate gathers to
discuss many pressing issues this is
where the emperor throws things around
for better or worse
wow I know right each part belongs to
the numerous representatives and
delegates
which one belongs to the clones no
they never have why not we're part of
this galaxy too I am working to change
that to ensure you all have the same
rights as any Galactic citizen no
oppress them segregate them don't don't
do that
assassin
it appears Rampart is resourceful in
covering up his misdeeds oh yeah which
is why I intend to be equally
resourceful I'm going to blow up
Coruscant
I've got a Zillow because if you're
intent on seeing this through then there
is someone you should speak with but her
cooperation may not be forthcoming
halibutoni
oh
former senator for kamino she was part
of the defense finance committee
she's the worst follow the money it
always leaves a trail this is great I
was wondering what happened to her
follow the money it's always she's the
worst she was so annoying and Clone Wars
Senator petone oh other turntables
funding for the cloning facilities in
siphoned off for over the past year your
people deserve why people are gone
a few remaining caminoans scattered
throughout the Galaxy are of no
importance to me
ouch
it was my home I saw the Empire destroy
everything and I'm angry it's not right
can't read her facial expressions did
Admiral rempart divert the funds
you already know the answer she needs to
hear it
my word won't do you any good
you need concrete proof I need both and
I'm running out of time
I love this little political thriller I
know it's great it seems like such a
like it's it's solidified the importance
of bad batch
we improvise
they are like an improv Troop
[Laughter]
I don't watch that show
whose clone Is It Anyway
[Music]
let's have a score this season has been
a plus we won't get across the shipyard
undetected
[Music]
I think they're gonna get caught
[Laughter]
Don't Look Down Don't Look Down
that shouldn't be funny
I hope there's treasure yeah oh sweet we
can make a boatload of money too I said
I feel like Rampart anticipated this
it's not an idiot kind of stupid to
leave it on the ship we have a possible
security breach Patrol squads to trench
Alpha 7 on both sentries report to the
bridge notice there's no red paint on
the ship anymore
[Music]
it's my kind of retrofit
I've got a bad feeling about
[Music]
much longer I am Expediting the final
transfer as quickly as possible yikes
[Music]
oh they're going all out it's a security
breach Greg they're gonna blow up
rampart's ship got nothing else to do
oh cool
awesome
should the bad batch just take the whole
ship yeah why not City transfer is
complete activate
oh is that what they're doing it looks
like it's got no choice I gotta Escape
Grand Theft Starship
[Music]
this is awesome we need an exit strategy
got one we're going over them over them
oh my God
it's me learning how to drive
I need Escape pods are not operational
we only need them to eject I can handle
the rest this shouldn't be interesting
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
bad
I was off by 6.4 meters not my best
dumbass
secret tunnel secret tunnel
well wow what a [__] draw any attention
to themselves yeah
we cannot take you on your word when you
have given us reason not to and what
reason is that you were responsible for
diverting kamino in funding to outside
projects without Senate approval wow
they're doing this right now formal
investigation should clear things up
unless you want to tell us now where
those funds went
[Laughter]
[Music]
Rampart you did not prepare an alibi
here did you get this to Senator Tucci
hurry the funds you are referring to
were redistributed your actions began
months prior to the loss of topoka City
keep delaying what exactly are you
implying I asset that the kamino and
cloning facilities were intentionally
eliminated
oh damn can't believe this made it to
the floor of the Senate I know well
if there are no further I hope she zip
lines down there
I'm coming
from these proceedings and she be
Centered for her misconduct oh God
oh I hope the evidence hasn't been yeah
and it's not just Rampart and his
boyfriend on a beat streaking new
evidence has come to light which must be
considered
I hope it's real evidence to not gonna
recovered command Lord from Admiral
rampart's Benita
oh my God
oh my God that is wild
oh damn this shit's going down I can't
believe they just did that
[Applause]
oh the emperor is making an appearance
oh he's been there this he's there all
the time probably huh
that was crazy
that's so cool it would appear that
Senator chucci's horrific assertions are
correct blame it all Rampart vote attack
on Camino was a cowardly act by Admiral
Rampart to further
I was following orders
[Applause]
my gratitude to Senator chuchi for
exposing a rogue element within our
ranks
oh this is clever
Admiral Rampart will face the
consequences for his treasury he did not
act alone
clones under his command so blindly
followed Waters inflicting such Carnage
without hesitation you
oh
perhaps
it is time for the change
now more than ever oh man he managed to
spin it it is my opinion that it's
legislation is our future wow we shall
Usher in a new ill heralded by the
Imperial storms Target
wow damn I love Palpatine Palpatine was
one step ahead of us during the war and
he's still several steps ahead of us
we played right into his hands he is
blonde
[Music]
he told the truth he Twisted it to his
Advantage the emperor wanted us to
implicate Rampart to get what he was
after all along passing the Bell the
fate of all the Clones is now sealed
what's gonna happen to them I don't know
but I will keep fighting for the Clones
thank you
wherever you end up
remember what I said
um
don't get into trouble without us oh
I'm going with Rex
oh this is something I have to do but we
need you too keep up with your training
while I'm gone huh understood
oh
that is so heartbreaking not even a
heads up
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God
[Music]
proud of echo
damn it I love Echo now we're gonna
barely see him
I don't know about that or Omega I
purchase ruining everything
[Laughter]
God I almost cried this episode what the
heck
wow
you know
Palpatine
is such a good politician
I enjoyed every minute of the political
thriller of the past two episodes yeah
that was it's brilliant uh
also explains why we'd never heard
Rampart in the uh you know
I love that Palpatine was actually just
there anticipating and waiting
because everyone was like he's gone he's
whatever they're like no no she's like
right down there every every meeting
he's just right there chilling reading
biting Mike James
he doesn't even like make an effort to
look welcoming you know well he's he was
deformed an attempt on my life I know
it's it's all Dragged In Black
yeah it's um that was a great last few
minutes she's like oh shoot we're going
down they really did this holy crap
how's it going to change all Palpatine's
one step ahead it was I mean you and I
were both having the same exact thought
which is like wow this is
huge implications on the entire Star
Wars timeline yeah and then for
Palpatine to just brilliantly uh to use
it to get what he wanted to get rid of
the Clones like oh that was genius
because that because it's like I kept
thinking like I think Rampart would have
prepared for a situation like this but
he didn't but palps did yeah yeah and I
mean that's Palpatine probably was
looking for it I mean because that was
that was my initial question was was it
a very quick very intelligent pivot or
is that Palpatine's plan all along
um and uh what does it matter no you're
right well that's the thing it sounds
like it was a backup plan yeah I don't
think he like pivoted at the last minute
I'm sure it was a backup plan yeah I
could always put the blame on uh on
Rampart it's uh it's definitely I mean
it was it was great seeing uh just some
of these like minor characters from The
Clone Wars get to step up and such
interesting ways I mean that's what's
really neat about a show like this is
because it is building upon something
that you know existed for almost a
decade uh
you don't have to worry about so much of
the backstory and you can just like dive
in
um yeah I appreciate that too Matt this
episode was a really great one I feel
like these last two have been very very
solid and uh specifically the way how
this one played out to actually have the
batch involved because I was making a
crack it's true though that the best
episodes have been without the batch I
just feel like the Clone Wars and then
to have the batch actually be very
integral to advancing the plot moving
forward yeah yeah I heard he would be
reprizing I think that was revealed in
press release yeah I think it'd be
surprising which I think is really cool
it was like it was a great experience
sorry I just was I was like yeah uh
um but yeah to have the batch involved
in this episode of course working with
Rex again showing more of their
implementation as actually being part of
the rise of the rebellion and finding
that purpose in this galaxy you know
obviously Echoes on that side but to see
like how the the batch themselves are
feeling more drawn towards it I wonder
if this is the formula for the rest of
the season you know where it's in
episode two kind of filler uh important
well you mean standard television and
there's no such thing as filler in the
bad batch uh sure but at least in my
humble opinion uh but this idea of an
episode or two where we're with Rex
hopefully Cody and you know the uh now
echo which I'm uh I'm really glad they
did uh at the top of the episode
um just that like
few seconds that we had with with Echo
um just like reminded me how little time
that we've had with this character that
um I mean them joining the batch uh was
the big appeal to me getting into the
bad batch in the first place I mean he
has the goodbye with the Clones to join
the batch now he has a goodbye with a
batch to the original like all right
cheers on your way nice to meet you
don't get eaten yeah whatever you saw to
do all right
it's like so emotional with the Clones
best of luck to you I uh yeah Dave
filoni if you're watching uh if D
Bradley Baker uh is having like any
threat stuff Greg and I got you yeah we
got you man we got you mate we got your
brother
uh very good thank you so uh yeah I mean
I really I'm not gonna lie it's gonna be
really really hard to go back uh to
dealing with
all of the really annoying
I don't know I mean it's wonderful in
its own
I don't want to go any more treasure
hunts I want to just do this for the
rest why not I just they haven't got
anything how many pieces of treasure
have they procured that's successful
classic that's classic it's that's
that's a Trope which I would treasure
hunters and bounty hunt and and people
who try to uh reclaim stuff they don't
walk away with a prize that's the Trope
all I'm saying is I'll go along with
said and all of that but if we don't get
Hondo anaka I'm gonna be really really
sad I'd say just an episode of focusing
on Sid making phone calls getting faxes
I gotta got a deal for you uh yeah yeah
I mean I I don't I'm not really looking
forward to that either but who knows
some of them end up being really fun
yeah they're fun I it's just I mean but
no there's a lot to have been like
actual genuinely like really good
television and really good animated
stuff well it I mean it holds up I mean
uh there was parts of this episode and
the previous episode that felt like the
political tension and suspense that like
a house of cards like yeah uh which when
you look at Palpatine
um Kevin Spacey Vibes uh but I I thought
it was interesting to you know as the
emperor to no longer be in every
proceeding like they had been as the
chancellor but in the few moments when
they do speak and show up it's a big
deal yeah you know and they were able to
leverage that so perfectly yeah
that's perfect and I love how you make
Germans game no I mean he's he's great
um and somehow
he returned yeah so you know we're real
jazzed about that it is interesting
seeing how Andor and bad batch are both
filling in this gap of how did the
Rebellion come to rise yeah well I'm I'm
sure before the end of this season we'll
get a little bit of mon mothma who
honestly I'm surprised we haven't really
seen her uh yeah at least in the past
two episodes so much of what they talk
about is money Trails too I mean her
money was for a different cause but uh
you know like the way they uh speaking
of which Monmouth has set up a GoFundMe
yeah so if you can contribute uh
um Nana this this is really great and uh
I'd like that Rampart got taken down and
at least know some truths about you
can't trust everything I mean I like
when the showdowns at the Senate are fun
we've had quite a few of them showdowns
at the center agreed and they don't
always have to involve throwing the the
Senators pulpits at each other
so uh the pen is mightier than the sword
or the indeed lightsaber I suppose in
this metaphor indeed Michael Tesla uh
well I can't wait for the next episode
yeah yeah I can't wait for it either
probably gonna get some Nerf nuggets
I hope so
um this was great and this was exciting
and uh I thought the last few minutes
were just they very much excellent and
surprising too do you think we're gonna
see Rampart again Rampart
um avian season three when he's like in
prison and has a beard yeah he's doing
pull-ups I feel like I feel like we're
gonna get some uh
uh
uh can be fun there's a lot of really
cool underworld characters there in the
course oh they totally executed him he's
totally dead oh they're not gonna keep
them alive They're Gonna Keep Rampart
alive I don't I feel like that's uh
they've got a budget he's gonna be like
one of those Futurama heads
glasses was he one of the frozen bodies
in Kenobi when he was walking down yeah
yeah that's what they make snoke out of
is uh
oh could I heard it here first it's all
it's all connected yeah everything we
must get an answer for everything Star
Wars this boy this one timeline you
gotta get an answer for it all but yeah
guys thank you so much for being here
um this was a blasty blast and uh can't
wait to see oh man we got what six left
we only have six more episodes of the
bad batch left I'm so Jazzy Mandalorian
will be starting soon um while this is
finished are you kidding me Mandalorian
comes out March I'm not sure I can talk
about all those things at the same time
I love Mandalore it's my favorite Star
Wars thing I haven't I haven't seen it
I'm kidding it's amazing and I'm excited
to hopefully talk about it legit my
favorite Star Wars thing ever full stop
I'm I'm more of a holiday special
all I'm saying is Chewie's family
deserved better uh like uh I mean I like
I like the movies
I specifically like the original Clone
Wars animated movie oh yeah that's
everyone's favorite that's why this is
such a big show Zero The Hut the
spin-off if we don't do it what's the
point yes sure all right guys thank you
for being here we'll see you all soon
see you soon
foreign